by the way women seem to love murderers
like my wine I'm fascinating right like
they're all against like rude Behavior
but like my wife can't get enough of
that Dateline show right yeah my wife
watches that the amount of times I've
gone to sleep where I just say that it
was a quiet town right things like this
weren't supposed to happen right they
were in love until or so it appeared or
so it appeared yeah no that why is that
what's you know my wife claims that she
watches it because she thinks what would
I do in that situation and like you know
I mean I I mean I guess I would I for a
while was watching Those Behind the
Scenes prison things trying to come up
with a plan of what I would do before I
finally came to the obvious answer which
was I would get raped repeatedly